Marvel Studios just announced a new
wakanda series coming to Disney Plus in
2024 we have the official synopsis for
this new project and we have a change in
name to Spider-Man freshman year it is
no longer called Spider-Man freshman
year but don't worry this is not in any
way bad news for the upcoming series
we'll go through these updates in this
video and go through what Marvel
projects are coming out in 2024 it
Remains the Same as far as Marvel movies
go Deadpool 3 is the only Marvel movie
coming out in 2024 that takes place in
the MCU however we do have other Marvel
movies coming out that are going to
still be pretty dang important for their
future franchises as well so with those
movies and the announcement of this new
series coming to Disney Plus for Marvel
Studios we're getting more Marvel
content in 2024 than we thought we were
going to get which is a great thing so A
lot's breakdown let's dive into it but
first if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest Marvel content and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you are
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick one winner at the end of
each month so we've known now for many
many years since basically the beginning
of phase 4 maybe even earlier on that
Marvel Studios was making multiple
series on Disney plus that were going to
be about wakanda a bunch of different
aspects of wakanda some about some
characters like it was that there was
going to be an aoi series and there
still very well could be but as far as
official announcements we haven't had
that many however last night at Disney
they screened a couple of episodes of
Marvel Studios what if season 2 in which
before they officially announced a new
series coming to Disney Plus for wakanda
titled eyes of wakanda this is going to
officially be an animated series and
they have announced that it is coming in
2024 and like I mentioned we do have a
synopsis for it and the synopsis reads
as follows throughout wakandan history
brave warriors have been tasked to
travel the world retrieving dangerous
vibranium artifacts this is their story
and I quite like this idea I like it so
much that I wish this wasn't exactly an
animated series however I look forward
to it nonetheless and I'm really excited
to see the dangerous vibranium artifacts
that they're going to discover
throughout the entire history of wakanda
people have been trying to break in and
steal artifacts that could be one aspect
of what is going to happen in this
animated series people break in like
claw we might actually see claw we might
actually see some more killmonger story
and some people from wakanda go outside
of wakanda to try and retrieve what was
stolen also at the same time perhaps
some vibranium landed elsewhere in the
world and wakanda had to go retrieve the
vibranium that landed in other parts of
the world so that they were the only
people who could have vibranium because
they did not trust the rest of the world
to have it which we know is how wakand
felt until tchala became king and opened
his resources up to the world for the
very first time at the ending of the
first black panther film and part of the
story could take place as a consequence
of that as well as to Chala opening up
wakanda's resources and revealing them
themselves to the world black panther
wakanda forever showed us that people
want vibranium and they are willing to
search for it themselves and try to get
as close to wakanda if not inside
wakanda to try and obtain vibranium plus
not to mention there are countless
mercenaries in Marvel Comics history
that they could have try and steal
vibranium from wakanda so that could be
a part of the story as well there are
really a lot of ways they could take
this story and it's really exciting to
hear about and it's really exciting to
hear that it's coming next year which
really is only a few weeks away so it's
great we're getting another project in
2024 because we weren't supposed to get
that many since they delayed many of the
movies and of course like I mentioned in
the beginning they have officially
announced that Spider-Man freshman year
is no longer titled Spider-Man freshman
year it is now called friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man this is also an
official announcement from Marvel
Studios this was also announced at the
wh if season 2 event and they have
confirmed that this is indeed going to
release in 2024 and again as far as
we're concerned they have not changed
anything about this project everything
is pretty much still the same each
episode the same the characters are
still going to be the same the story is
pretty much going to be the same Peter
Parker is not mentored by Iron Man AKA
Tony Stark but Norman Osborne will also
see some very familiar foes like Doc O
so that's all staying the same the
story's the same don't worry about that
this should be a pretty killer animated
project that I know many people
including myself are really looking
forward to so what does 2024 now have in
store for us well these are all of the
upcoming projects from all the different
universes and multiverses we should say
from the main MCU to these animated
projects that do not connect to the MCU
to the Sony spider verse because there
are many Sony spiderverse films that are
coming out next year so as far as 2024
is concerned we have three animated
series coming from Marvel Studios and
Disney plus and those are like we just
mentioned eyes of wakanda then of course
we have your friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man which is the new title for it
and then we have X-Men 97 and as far as
animated series goes these all sound
really really interesting and exciting
so I'm looking forward to these now
unfortunately we don't have any release
dates for the these three projects right
here we have been told X-Men 97 should
be early 2024 we were also led to
believe that Spider-Man freshman year as
it was titled before was supposed to
come sometime probably late 2024 which
would mean eyes of wakanda would
probably be mid 2024 but your friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man and eyes of
wakanda could be switched and really
X-Men 97 could be switched as well so if
we hear any official release dates for
any of these we'll be sure to do videos
on them so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell there is is also
the possibility that we could be getting
Marvel Zombies in 2024 that is another
animated project although we haven't
heard anything official about that yet
but kicking off Disney Plus for the MCU
liveaction will be eeko coming out on
January 10th and this is supposed to be
pretty raw for the old Daredevil Netflix
series fans this pretty much has the
same tone and Vinnie denafo stated that
we should enjoy this one so don't sleep
on this one they are going to be
releasing every episode simultaneously
at at the same time so January 10th the
whole series drops then we have Madam
web that is coming February 14th of 2024
for those who are fans of the
spiderverse or even just curious to see
what direction they are taking it Madame
Webb is supposed to be a very important
movie for that Sony Spider-Man universe
so if you're curious don't miss out on
that movie then we have our 1 MCU film
of 2024 and that is what everybody is
calling the MCU savior Deadpool 3 Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine is returning and of
course we we've heard just a ton of
reports about original X-Men returning
maybe some old Fantastic 4 members
returning some variants of characters
that we know and love are going to be in
it overall it just sounds like this
movie is going to be absolutely crazy
and probably one of the best things that
has come from Marvel in a pretty long
time so mark your calendar for that it
comes out July 26th of 2024 then we have
on August 30th 2024 Craven the hunter
this was originally supposed to come out
in 2023 but due to all of the delays
from the strikes and such pushed it to
2024 there's been some rumors that there
is going to be a mention of some
Spider-Man Connection in this film or a
Spider-Man setup in this film so if
you're very curious about this one be
sure to go see it in theaters also it's
supposed to be pretty brutal as we've
seen from the red band trailer so
hopefully it's a step up in Sony's
Marvel game then we have Agatha darkhold
Diaries which is currently slated for
September 19th of 20124 and to end it
all we have venom 3 coming out November
8th of 202 24 and everyone is looking at
Venom 3 wondering if we are going to see
a Spider-Man show up not necessarily the
Spider-Man like Tom Holland Spider-Man
but perhaps Andrew Garfield Spider-Man
shows up maybe Toby Maguire's or maybe a
completely different Spider-Man could
show up in the Sony Spider-Man universe
Tom Hardy has stated that his end goal
is Spider-Man vers Venom and he has
announced that Venom 3 is his last Venom
movie so fingers crossed Spider-Man a
Spider-Man of some sort shows up in
venom 3 and that's all we have for 2024
coming from Marvel in every way shape or
form that has been officially announced
at least go ahead and let us know what
project you were most excited for in
2024 I got to say mine is Deadpool 3 but
I really am looking forward to basically
all of these projects coming out but let
us know your thoughts in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to the channel so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
Marvel news you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof